there's only one star in the planet that
could surpass a brad and Leo sighting
Britney and Bo Sam Ascari's official red
carpet debut was only slightly bigger
news than the diamond sparkle if she
wore on that finger igniting rumors of
an engagement but a source close to
Britt tells et that the couple is not
engaged the ring was simply a design
statement this is our first premiere
once upon a time how do you throw some
Britt rocked a single shoulder midi by
nicki we're told she was specifically
looking for a sexy red cocktail dress
the couple's date night was a plan
outing but it's no surprise to us why
she decided to be there Brad Pitt of
course because he is really beautiful
like the first celebrity crushes Brad
Pitt as met Brad Pitt once mm-hmm but
the red carpet was packed with a listers
last night but sadly missing the late
Luke Perry who made his final film
appearance in the movie his son Jack
posted this sweet tribute to him
climbing the billboard on sunset
boulevard that bares his father's image
Luke's son actually worked on the movie
he looks so badass up there on that
billboard and it was such a loving
tribute to his father it really it made
my whole day a very touching tribute and
I'm actually gonna be sitting down with
Luke's son Jack tomorrow and we're gonna
chat all about what Luke went to
Hollywood and his legacy so I'm excited
[Music]